des souterrains aux pavés les égouts
type profession aux pénibilités
multiples manifestent contre la réforme
des retraites depuis décembre 2000 jean
important de se battre je me dis pour
l'avenir pour nous pour nos enfants
les toc comme on les appelle avait peu
un peu obtenu des avantages liés à leurs
conditions de travail
en 1978 l'un d'eux à lyon résume ces
difficultés les gauthier n'est pas connu
son travail se fait bien sûr en
souterrain dans des conditions
difficiles des positions souvent
inconfortables vous pouvez voir des
ouvrages de faible hauteur dans des
conditions d'insalubrité une odeur
nauséabonde dans les boues et aussi avec
de graves risques puisque nous avons
fréquemment trop fréquemment des
égoutiers qui sont l'objet d'
intoxication
sans compter les charges lourdes et
l'obscurité
les égoutter cumule ce que l'on
n'appelait pas encore des critères de
pénibilité
en compensation à l'époque ils
travaillent six heures par jour et
peuvent partir à la retraite à 50 ans
vous estimez avoir indiqué
pénible ac oui à cette pénible parce que
vous voyez bien que nous on est toujours
enfermé dans les égouts avec le temps la
technologie est venu appuyer l'égoutier
dans cette tâche il doit néanmoins
continuer à arpenter les conduits et
mettre la main dans la boue transpire
comme à spa pour un senior en 2010 après
la réforme des retraites l'âge minimum
de départ des égoutiers passe de 50 à 52
ans la profession accuse le coup
d'autant qu'en 2011
l'inserm confirme la pénibilité extrême
du métier selon leur étude
l'espérance de vie des égoutiers de 17
ans inférieure à celle de la population
française
tout ce que j'ai vu c'est qu'ils
n'avaient pas atteint l'âge de la
retraite la plupart pour pour mourir est
bon on regarde on regarde du reste de la
population je sais pas je pense qu'il ya
quand même un souci chez nous la réforme
des retraites de 2020 prévoit la
disparition de la catégorie insalubre à
laquelle le mettais des goûters
appartient tout comme les éboueurs plus
de retraite à cinquante deux ans donc
mais à la place ils cumuleront des
points de pénibilité pour racheter des
trimestres et partir avant l'âge de
départ de tous les français
[Musique]